in Trump's America rape is a
pre-existing condition under the new
health care bill rape could be a
pre-existing condition
Trump's health care bill allows rape to
be a pre-existing condition rape and
domestic violence could be pre-existing
conditions these are all real headlines
from mainstream media outlets New York
magazine Huffington Post the independent
from the UK and CNN under the American
Health Care Act states have the ability
to opt out of federal regulations
requiring insurance companies to cover
pre-existing conditions naturally the
left immediately conjured up images of
people injured the most horrifying
possible way rape and then suggested
that the bill would suddenly leave rape
victims adrift here's a New York
magazine quote under Obamacare
pre-existing conditions were guaranteed
to receive coverage among them sexual
assault the American health care act is
going to change that in addition to rape
postpartum depression cesarean sections
and surviving domestic violence are all
considered pre-existing conditions so
let's parse this for a second according
to the leftist media if you suffer an
injury in a terrible situation the
situation itself is now a pre-existing
condition in other words these headlines
could just have easily read quote in
terms America car crashes are a
pre-existing condition or under the new
health care bill soccer accidents could
be a pre-existing condition the bill
itself says that pre-existing conditions
are pre-existing conditions nowhere does
it give a list of pre-existing
conditions including rape or sexual
assault because these are activities
leading to injury not actual injuries
the leftist case here is as usual
idiotic events are not pre-existing
conditions injuries that occur as a
result of events if they occur before
you attempt to buy insurance and are
definitionally pre-existing conditions
duh but the debate has now been so
skewed that we think the government can
magically have health insurance cover
rape which doesn't even make sense if no
injury occurred requiring medical
attention due to a rape what would the
insurance companies you to cover it prey
hunt down rapists yet the people who
believe that government can protect you
from all ills and apparently send
insurance adjusters into the streets
Charles Bronson style to mete out
justice and prevent rape are out in
force today quote under new religious
liberty Act hospitals can deny rape
victims emergency contraception under
AHCA rape will be a pre-existing
condition
Cady's Nita Clara Jeffrey new version of
AHCA wants to punish both special ed
victims and rape victims good luck in
2018 boys here's a list of all members
of Congress
voted yes to AHCA these people believe
rape is a pre-existing condition this
argument is the equivalent of saying
that Obamacare sought to hurt rape
victims by throwing people off their
individual insurance plans Obamacare may
well have thrown people off their
individual insurance plans but it wasn't
because there are rape victims come on
people
I'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show so much stupid so little time we'll
talk about the leftist reactions the
american health care act and the rollout
of such we'll also talk about why the
republicans screw up every single major
piece of legislation they apparently
bring to the floor we'll also talk about
marine lepen and sally 8 and all the
news of the day but first i want to say
thank you to our new sponsors over
upside comm so if you are a business
traveler and particularly to travel
alone upside comm is made for you every
time you buy a TripIt upside comm you
save a ton of money and they give you an
amazon gift card worth one hundred two
hundred even three hundred dollars every
single time so what they do is they
bundle your flight and your hotel
together for one low price because
you're traveling alone they can afford
to do this bundled pricing saves money
especially on business travel so up side
gives you free Amazon gift cards your
frequent business traveler your company
saves a bunch of money just on the
prices and then you're the one who ends
up actually taking the Amazon gift cards
and you still get all of your miles you
should definitely check out upside calm
flights and hotels booked together for
one low price and right now if you go to
up side calm and you use that radio
listener promo code Ben if you go to up
side calm you use the promo code Ben you
get at least $200 in gift cards with a
minimum purchase so that is a pretty
awesome deal I love amazon.com and you
know obviously there's no better place
to have a gift card so go to up side
calm you get cheaper flight plus you get
the kickback from upside calm in terms
of the Amazon card it's just terrific
your company benefits you benefit check
out upside calm the guy who found that
it also found another one these major
travel company so they really know what
they're doing they also have in-person
help so if you call them ups a real
person is going to answer the phone and
help you out upside calm again use that
promo code been received at least $200
in gift cards with minimum purchase
minimum purchase required and you can
see the site for the details on what
that means okay so lots going on in the
news first I'll give my brief reaction
to the blowout election in France
marine lepen gets blue
in the French election by Emmanuel
macron Emmanuel macron is a first-time
office holder he is the youngest
president of France the youngest leader
of France since apparently Napoleon
Bonaparte he won 90% of Paris he blew
the he blew marine lepen ouches the head
of the National Front she ditched for
association with the National Front
going into the election cycle a lot of
people including President Trump were
excited about the possibility of marine
lepen because she is very harsh with
regard to the borders instead she gets
absolutely wallop she loses 65 to 35 the
polls were skewed but they were skewed
actually a marine lepen direction the
pollsters didn't want to be surprised by
marine lepen so instead they were
actually oversampling apparently her
crowd 1/3 of french voters spoiled their
ballots or abstained they didn't like
either of these two choices and the big
generational gap is basically lepen ran
even with McCrone among young people
among old people he blew out marine
lepen what does this election say so
there was this weird idea that
nationalism all over the world was on
the rise that nationalism all over the
all over the planet was on the rise and
that you're going to see nation after
nation following the brexit model
following the Trump model and they're
going to elect nationalist leaders now
normally that only happens in opposition
historically speaking the reason you get
nationalist movement is in opposition to
other nationalist movements so for
example in Europe you said the rise of a
lot of nationalist leaders during the
1930s because there are lots of
nationalist leaders arising so what that
means that if you have a German
nationalist leader coming to the floor
then it's a good shot that you might get
a British nationalist leader coming to
the floor in reaction to the German
nationalist leader nationalism tends to
breed nationalism in other countries
just as international as intends to
breed internationalism in other
countries but the French election was
not going to be a reaction to Trump in
the sense that they are going to now
effectuate some sort of national stand
against Trump in fact if there was any
Trump effect to this election at all
which I really doubt if there was any it
was a nationalist reaction against Trump
by electing someone that Trump didn't
like you see the point so here is the
here's the problem with reading too much
into this election cycle it is not a
rejection of nationalism wholesale it's
a rejection of marine lepen and this is
a rejection of the old order remember
McCrone was not running associated with
any party and marine lepen was running
with the National Front the two historic
parties that have won in France
are the Socialist Party the sort of
Francois Matt around party and then the
and then the Conservative Party in
France which was never all that
conservative Francois Fillon was the
Theon was the was the candidate they're
both he and the Socialists guy ended up
being ousted in the first round he had
two newcomers running against each other
and that I think is the common the
common thread that holds together
Britain and holds together America and
holds together a France in sort of the
lecture electoral trend I don't think
that there is a coherent program from
any of these countries I don't think
there's a coherent right-wing movement
that is now on the rise anywhere I think
what you're getting instead is just a
reaction to we hated what came before
give us something new give us something
new whether it's David Cameron and get
rid of that guy and put in Theresa May
or whether it is Barack Obama and we
hate Hillary Clinton so get rid of her
and put in Donald Trump who's completely
new or whether it is we're sick of
Francois Fiona and we don't want marine
lepen fishies all too scary to put
McCrone because he's new I think there
is this reactionary feel about politics
that politics is failing and therefore
we need someone new in place and marine
lepen was just too scary now I also
think that on the left it's too much to
suggest that marine lepen was ousted
because of her border views I don't
think that's right I think she was
ousted because she has this
long-standing history with the National
Front which scares people rightly so
because the National Front easing is
historically an anti-semitic party she's
moved away from that because she wanted
to win an election but historically they
weren't an somatic party her father was
a deep-rooted anti-semite that she had
to condemn and and so I think that there
is the possibility every possibility
that if there were a conservative
candidate in France who came along and
we're not marine lepen and said we need
to do something about all the immigrants
who are swapping us particularly from
Islamic countries I think that that
person might have a better shot marine
lepen was just too off-putting and so
that's the result it sort of suggests
what might happen in the United States
if there any sort of ramifications for
the u.s. it would sort of suggest in the
United States that if there were
somebody on the Left who are willing to
make a nationalist argument and not be
an old fuddy duddy like Hillary Clinton
and no one likes that they might have a
shot of knocking off Trump because Trump
is sort of a marine lepen in in the
sense that there are a lot of people who
just like me has very high negatives if
there was somebody from left who were
not so scary but we're a fresh face and
we're willing to express the sort of
coop some Trump's language then Trump
might be in trouble in 2020 so that's
the
only thing that I'll say about the
marine lepen election I don't think it's
earth-shattering I don't think it's a
massive win for the left I don't think
it's a massive loss for the right I
think that marine lepen is a scary
character for a lot of people and she
was not the best candidate for the right
but the right is on the move just
because new stuff is on the move and
they haven't seen anything even remotely
right-wing in France plus by the way
she's a socialist I mean the fact is
that her domestic policy is big
government socialism anti-trade
socialism so the idea that it was sort
of right versus left in France is not
really true as nationalists left versus
international is left but nationalist
international is left that makes any
sense a sort of nationalist France that
says we are our common characters to be
internationalist okay so that's one
thing that's in the news the other thing
that's in the news this morning is sort
of the new breaking news it's le AIT's
is the former acting Attorney General
she took over for the for the former
attorney general Loretta Lynch from
Loretta Lynch stepped down and then she
was for a short period of time the
acting Attorney General she obviously
was messing with President Trump and
then he fired her she's now testifying
before Congress and there is a and there
is a suggestion that it's a Donald Trump
goes on Twitter this morning and
president Trump tweets out that somebody
needs to ask her under oath why she why
there was all this information leaking
to the press after she talked to the
White House Counsel spelled seal and cou
ncil he meant co un SEL like the White
House Counsel but President Trump is not
bad with the spelling in any case she's
testifying on the hill and the left is
using this as an opportunity to say
Sally Yates was really Elstad because
she knew too much about Mike Flynn and
she had to be silenced and so now
they're very excited that she's on the
hill and here's Trump responding trying
to go after Sally ate doesn't make him
look great meanwhile the Obama
administration officials are leaking old
Obama administration officials are
leaking to the press that Obama had
warned President Trump about hiring Mike
Flynn now remember Sally Yates according
to the left was fired because she knew
too much about Mike Flynn that's what
was going on here was Mike Flynn was you
it was in heavy with the Russians and
Sally Yates knew it and then Trump fired
her in order to cover that up for some
odd reason which wouldn't make a lot of
sense because then she could just
probably go speak about it under oath
which is what she's going to do today in
any case there's a story out today that
I just wanted to bunk because I think
it's silly that President Obama warned
Trump about putting Flynn in his cab
okay so did everybody who's a
conservative a lot of people were very
skeptical of Mike Flynn they didn't
think that he was qualified for this the
suggestion seems to be that Obama warned
Trump that Flynn was enthralled with
Russians and Trump ignored that there's
been no evidence of that whatsoever that
Obama was warning about that and if
Obama knew about that then why did he
retain his security clearance he still
had full security clearance in 2016 from
the Department of Defense did Mike Flynn
even after Obama fired him in 2012 or
2014 so it none of it makes any sense I
think this is a little bit more of the
the Russian rumor mongering that you're
hearing from the left I don't see any
material here to suggest that Trump was
in deep with the Russians because of
Mike Flynn and then fired Sally Yates at
least I haven't seen any any material to
support such sub positions right now
okay so I also want to talk about the
blow this is a big topic that I actually
want to talk about those are sort of
topics of the day but now I really want
to talk about at length the American
Health Care Act because the the Trump
care that has been rolled out Democrats
are responding in predictably stupid
fashion as I mentioned a little bit
earlier their first course of attack was
to claim that the AHCA makes rape a
pre-existing condition as I mentioned
earlier this is just stupid that doesn't
even make logical sense rape is not a
medical condition okay so you can't have
a condition no insurance coverage ever
has covered rape it's covered injuries
that may be resulting from rape but that
has nothing to do with with covering
rape itself that's silliness so you know
number one there's that number two this
bill doesn't actually revoke
pre-existing conditions it gives States
the ability to opt out of required
pre-existing conditions and the vast
majority of employer-provided insurance
programs cover pre-existing conditions
medicaid covers pre-existing conditions
so the idea that people are just being
left without any coverage on
pre-existing conditions is just silly so
that argument is really dumb the other
argument that's been made is the left
are trotting out some of the worst
arguments ever on this on this bill
which is amazing because they're really
good arguments against this bill from
the left so for example they should be
saying it makes care it makes the the
acquisition of health insurance it could
make the acquisition of health insurance
more expensive for elderly people queer
only true clearly true okay this is the
the HCA Trump care makes it more
expensive for for older people it also
creates a coverage gap for poor people
because one
the things that it does is in
restructuring Medicaid it basically says
that it's going to lower the subsidies
for Medicaid on the state level and then
it's going to give grants it's going to
give you basically a tax credit for
buying health insurance but those tax
credits are not enough for poor people
and old sick people so it creates a
coverage gap for those people driving
them to rely on Medicaid which the
federal government is not spending as
much as they used to spend on so that
would be their best argument is that a
bunch of people are going to fall
through the cracks in this program
because again here is the bottom line
with regard to health insurance and this
is why it's so stupid to discuss health
insurance as the be-all end-all and the
bottom line is unless you're unless
you're going to mandate the pre-existing
conditions are covered and then issue a
mandate that everyone has to buy right
is what Switzerland does unless we're
going to do this there will be coverage
gaps there will be coverage gaps that's
just the way that this works once you
say pre-existing conditions have to be
covered prices are going to rise the
only way to cover that rise is either
with a massive subsidy and/or
nationalization of the program which if
you create massive subsidies by the way
the prices just continue to go up so it
doesn't really help anything you have to
keep subsidizing the program or you
nationalize the program altogether like
Britain or you know what Switzerland
does and you force people to pay eight
percent of their income into health
insurance as a start by the way that was
sort of what Romney care was and that's
what Obama's attempt at Obamacare was
although it was actually softer than
that Republicans have actually in some
ways done the worst of both worlds in
this bill they maintain pre-existing
conditions and then they've also removed
the mandate so that means that you're
actually exacerbating the death spiral
you don't have enough young healthy
people paying into the insurance
programs to keep these pre-existing it
conditions programs alive so that means
that it falls apart the way the
Republicans solve this is they say okay
states can opt out if they want but they
aren't going to opt out because not a
lot of governors are going to have the
political courage to opt out of the
system and then be told by their rivals
in the next election that they're the
ones who opted out of pre-existing
conditions in any case those aren't the
arguments the left are making those
would actually be pretty good arguments
those arguments they're making are of
course the stupidest arguments you can
make so Andrea Mitchell on NBC News she
says that the big problem here is that
there are too many white men making
healthcare decisions the celebration of
this on Thursday they were all mostly
all men and white men at that there was
no diversity there women's health issues
arguably are going to be
disproportionately affected take a look
at this Obamacare includes maternity and
newborn care preventive care mammograms
cervical cancer screenings birth control
all of this under the essential package
no longer required under this House bill
and the cameras yes there is the
important one because it's so stupid
look at all these horrible white men
look at all these terrible horrible
white men who are doing this thing how
could they possibly do this thing just
awful these terrible horrible white men
again this is intense ly stupid this is
a really bad argument that they're
making they're making a lot of bad
arguments lately and this is one of them
and then they're making me argument the
millions of people are going to die
because of health care the millions of
people are just going to fall apart and
be killed because of health care again
there's not a lot of evidence to suggest
that a lot of people might fall onto
Medicaid and the states will have to
pick up the slack but again that's
that's wildly exaggerated now I want to
break here and I want to talk more about
what the Republicans have been doing
because I think that actually is stupid
I don't know that well everybody was
celebrating on Friday and Thursday I
don't think that this is something
Republicans should necessarily be
celebrating over it's not quite that
easy but to hear that you're gonna have
to go over to daily wire.com right now
eight dollars a month become a
subscriber over at daily wired.com or if
you get the annual subscription at the
annual subscription and you too can
become a member of daily wire.com and
you can get a free copy of the arroyo a
fictional film set on the southern
border you can go check that out over at
Daley wire.com become a subscriber or if
you just want to listen later go over to
iTunes or SoundCloud and and become a
subscriber over there leave a review we
always appreciate it over at iTunes we
are the largest conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
you